I can grow lemons and oranges in the
snow I've developed a revolutionary
theory of genetics that doesn't even
require a laboratory I can take these
normal fruits and train them to survive
in the coal right dumping ice on them
I'll induce methylation that will alter
the expression of their DNA and their
seeds will produce offspring that can
grow in harsh winter conditions then
every generation that follows will be
able to survive and thrive in Siberia
with everything we know about genetics
this seems like one of the dumbest ideas
ever because it is but it wasn't just a
silly idea on the fringes of pseudo
science it became devastating policy
that killed tens of millions of people
so how how how did a poorly trained
glorified Gardener become one of the
most prolific Mass murderers in human
history and why didn't the scientific
Community stop him and what if one of
the worst scientists who ever lived was
so ridiculously absurdly wrong that he
actually started to be a little
right conmen usually get by on charm and
often good looks that's where the con
comes from he uses personality and
persuasion to gain someone's confidence
and Trust to exploit them troph L senka
was just scary in 1927 proed journalist
Vitali federovich said that tropine
danovich lenka's first impression gives
one the feeling of a toothache he
described Lenka as having an
insignificant face and that all one
remembers is his Sullen look creeping
along the Earth as if at the very least
he were ready to do someone in only a
ruthless authoritarian dictator would
trust someone like
that when Lena was just 29 and working
with beans at a remote experimental
station in azer ban profa described him
as a Barefoot scientist who scribbled
his quick calculations on a little old
piece of paper he was a Stern Everyman
citizen scientist and the brand new
Soviet Union had some serious food
problems had he been born just a few
years earlier or later lysa's
unremarkable upbringing and training
probably would have led to an anonymous
existence at a laboratory on the fringes
of the USSR and at most some trivial
advances in the cultivation of beans
instead his timing was perfectly
destructive which resulted in Lysa
derailing Soviet science eviscerating
the ranks of the ussr's most talented
researchers and ultimately killing tens
of millions of people and the degree to
which he set back Humanity's
understanding of genetics is
incalculable some unassuming scientists
like ignis sovis save countless lives
others like lka end them but how did a
crackpot quack even have the power and
influence to level the populations of
multiple countries social and political
revolution had been building in Russia
for Generations by 1917 the Romanov
Dynasty had been Empower for over 300
years and Zar Nicholas II who narrowly
quelled a 19 1905 Revolution by
promising Democratic reforms he
eventually rolled back had inadvertently
fueled a vision for a new Russian
identity one of
egalitarianism dignity and workers
rights World War I decimated Russia
several million were killed and the
country was completely unprepared
economically or logistically to engage
in the war which exposed every problem
with the romanov's archaic autocracy the
February and October revolutions ushered
in a new Russian era and when the
Bolshevik Red Army triumphed at the end
of the six-year-long Civil War Vladimir
lennin began to create a new Soviet man
the problem was figuring out how to make
sure he didn't starve to death real
quick this video is sponsored by better
heal if you watch my video on happiness
you'll know it's a complex and often
misunderstood concept and it's one
Complicated by personal life factors
that are a tangled web of temperament
and circumstances so it can be useful to
talk through your challenges with one of
better help's over 30,000 licensed
therapists and use my link
betterhelp.com
Vsauce just fill out a questionnaire to
help assess your specific needs and get
matched with a therapist often in less
than 48 hours you can choose to do a
phone call video call or messaging on a
schedule that works for you over 4
million people have used better help to
find the right therapist who will listen
and provide unbiased advice and if the
therapist you're first matched with
doesn't seem like a fit you can switch
easily to a new one at no extra cost so
click the link below to help support
this Channel and get 10% off your first
month of better Heth so you can connect
with a therapist and see if it helps you
that's betterhelp.com
Vsauce the Union of Soviet Socialist
republics was formed in 19 22 which
coincided with a horrific famine in a
people's tragedy Orlando FES wrote that
many thousands of cases of cism were
reported and that it was dangerous for
children to go out after dark since
there were known to be bands of Cs and
traitors who killed them to eat or sell
their tender flesh in one city 10
butcher shops were shut down for selling
human flesh and around vulga gangs sold
child meat as horse or beef and if you
think these sound like Boogeyman stories
there are pictures the Bolsheviks had
campaigned on a slogan of Peace land and
bread and when Joseph Stalin succeeded
lennin following his death in 1924 they
still hadn't figured out that bread part
Stalin's solution was collectivization
farmers and their land were forced into
collectives or organized or directly run
by the state Stalin hoped to harness
more manpower and take advantage of the
economies of scale that collectivization
and rapid industrialization would
deliver and there was a new Soviet man
crafted in the image of the proletariat
the destruction of the Kula class and
the presence of a strong Communist party
now they just needed a new Soviet
science trophi Lenka claimed that his
father really made the discovery that
would eventually upend Soviet Russia's
scientific Community there are two types
of wheat winter wheat and spring wheat
winter wheat is planted in the fall and
is harvested the following summer spring
wheat is planted in the spring and
harvested in the fall Lena's father
supposedly experimented with the process
of vernalization soaking and chilling
winter wheat to induce a brief period of
growth before entering dormy when it
encountered the cold and then growing
aggressive ively when spring warmth hit
vernalization was meant to make winter
wheat more resistant to harsh Winters
and to increase crop yields so more food
vernalization is a real thing it wasn't
as original as Lenka thought with
vernalization experiments in Ohio in the
1850s and cold layering farming
practices among menites already existing
Nikolai vavala one of the most revered
scientist in the early Soviet Union had
already overseen experiments with
vernalization but lka wanted to identify
how and why plants adapted to the annual
time and temperature cycle and then he
wanted to manipulated the Ukrainian
commissariat of Agriculture decided that
vernalization would eliminate winter
crop destruction and guard against
famine and by 1932 Lenka had his own
academic Journal the bulletin of
vernalization his own courses at the all
Union Institute of plant breeding in
Odessa and the full cooperation of the
Bureau of applied botney and to the
Soviet government the best part is that
lenko was the champion of a science that
could be understood and implemented by
the average farmer it was a science for
and of the people but as the people
started noticing lenka's work something
terrible happened to him they actually
thought about it plant physiologist
Nikolai maximov criticized lenka's
presentation of a paper at a 1929
scientific conference writing that the
results obtained by comrade lka do not
represent anything new in principle and
are not a scientific discovery in the
precise sense of the word and he
eviscerated Lena's incorrect use of
Statistics so after maximov's criticism
Lysa decided not to use statistics ever
ever ever again and to critics who
called for mathematical proof of his
claims he dismissed them by countering
that mathematics had no place in
biology in Stalin and the scientist
Simon in writes that Lena's ambition and
ego were so strong that he did not want
to be part of Maximum scientific
Community or any other scientific
Community he did not want his work
considered as part of an honorable
tradition he wanted credit all the time
for everything he touched the validation
for Lena's narcissism would be in the
crops it turns out that vernalization
was actually really really hard despite
being a simple concept seeds had to be
soaked for days spread out individually
not just dumped in a huge pile with a
bucket of water thrown on it and turned
repeatedly the conditions had to be
maintained consistently despite most of
the Farms not having refrigeration and
many of them having no electricity
whatsoever wet seeds were a perfect
breeding ground for seed killing
diseases and even the Practical elements
of planting much heavier soggy seeds
became a factor 80 years earlier those
experiments in Ohio concluded that it
just wasn't worth the trouble but all
these potential complications actually
helped lka avoid criticism in wrote that
if your crop failed what were you going
to blame the inadequacy of your
equipment the failure of your workers or
a state sanctioned agricultural Panacea
with the personal blessing of Stalin
yeah and he was being praised by vov who
said during a trip to the United States
that lysa's work would eventually allow
bananas to be grown in New York the
prospect of wheat that could beat
drought was exciting to a nation deep in
depression and failing Dust Bowl Farms
but when vov returned home he found that
he was blamed for agricultural failures
that led to a famine in which several
million Soviet citizens died the USSR
had committed to farming a hybrid
variety of maze from the United States
which produces more grain than wheat in
the same area the new hybrid variety had
increased crop yields in the US by up to
30% but maze was more sensitive than
wheat and the volatile Soviet weather
ruined the crop Lysa blamed it on incest
corn he said the imperialist capitalist
American Hybrid corn was inferior in
part because it was the direct direct
result of inbreeding and he doubled down
by directing peasants to strip Wheat by
hand to force different wheat crops to
crossbreed which he thought would keep
them from the same problems animals
experience from Perpetual inbreeding but
since wheat is a natural inbreeding crop
every bit of that effort was wasted and
just pointless as lenka's catastrophic
failures continued to mount the response
from the state finally was to fire him
just kidding he got a promotion lka
failed upward he became a full member of
the Ukraine Academy of Sciences armed
with greater notoriety and support and
no real scientific accountability he
moved on from Beans and wheat to
decoding The evolutionary processes of
life on Earth no big deal the study of
genetics in the early 20th century
constituted one of the most rapid
advances of Science in human history
Gregor Mendel's work on heredity with
peas was rediscovered in 1900 replacing
earlier theories of inheritance promoted
by Lamar and Darwin and it's important
to understand the difference between
those two the famous example is how
giraffes got such a long neck lamaran
theory suggests that straining upward
toward leaves very slowly lengthen
giraffe necks a trait which then passed
down to their offspring who did the same
until the length of the giraffe neck was
in a stable place genetically Darwin
said that the mutated freaks with the
longest necks happen to survive by 1910
Thomas Hunt Morgan had blown past Lamar
mle and Darwin he successfully used
fruit flies to show that genes reside on
chromosomes and are the delivery
mechanism for heredity Morgan won the
Nobel Prize for physiology or medicine
for his genetics research in the same
year that the holid doore ravaged
Ukraine and that Jean B's work with sea
urchin eggs suggested that DNA is found
in the cell nucleus while rnaa is found
in the cytoplasm meanwhile over in the
Soviet Union tropine Lenka insisted that
genes didn't exist at all in the rise
and fall of Titi Lenka jarus Medvedev
quotes him as saying bits of cell
nucleus or chromosome are not what
geneticists understand by the term Gene
the hereditary basis does not lie in
some special self-reproducing substance
the hereditary base is the cell which
develops and becomes an organism in this
cell different organel have different
significance but there is not a single
bit that is not subject to evolutionary
development basically what he's saying
is whatever happens to an organism and
whatever characteristics it acquires
will influence what is passed on to the
next Generation this was Lena's theory
of nutrients which defined nutrients as
all factors affecting plant growth and
posited that plants internalize
environmental conditions in such a way
that the resulting changes can be passed
down to offspring it was all part of his
law of phasic development which outlined
a series of phases which he never
actually identified that plants must go
through correctly to bear fruit and
dominant traits they were determined not
by genes but you guessed it by the
environment Lenka also promised that he
had developed a new variety of Wheat by
utilizing newly discovered principles of
genetic inheritance in five buckets in
the back of his Greenhouse which was
excellent timing considering his
vernalization miracle was a dud despite
this at a 1935 agricultural conference
Lenka continued to encourage the power
of vernalization and blamed the bis for
ruining its potential instead of helping
Collective Farmers they did their
destructive business both in the
scientific world and out of it a class
enemy is always an enemy whether he is a
scientist or not one thick mustachioed
member of the audience was so impressed
that he cheer Bravo comrade Lenka Bravo
trop Lenka had officially gained the
support of Joseph Stalin
himself Stalin loved Agriculture and
botney gardening was his only real hobby
or interest he desperately wanted the
entire Soviet Union to tend the same
Bountiful plants he did in his native
Georgia grapes t arines and peaches and
if Russians could acclimate to the
harshest Siberian conditions and their
children were even better adapted to
that climate why couldn't lemons be
trained to grow in Siberia too both
Stalin and Lysa completely rejected even
the simple mandelian inheritance the
punet square you learned in high school
showing different combinations of
dominant and recessive traits when peas
carry genes for both dominant purple
flowering and recessive white flowering
are combined you get three purples and
one white in the next generation one
purple that is purely dominant two
combinations of dominant and recessive
in which the white Gene is repressed and
one combination of recessive white but
think about what that meant for the
Soviet Union in the 1920s and 30s if
one's traits abilities and
characteristics are predetermined at At
All by genes how is that compatible with
a nation built on Promises of rejecting
in equality and promoting the creation
of a perfectly harmonious egalitarian
society and if it can be done if it was
even possible to influence genetic
improvement from one generation to the
next how could it ever be done quickly
enough when millions of your people are
starving to death you can't exactly wait
thousands of years for evolution to take
its course if the Soviet citizenry
followed a lamaran list model they could
be developed into the healthiest
strongest most intelligent most
productive and happiest people in the
world under the Darwin Western
capitalist Theory where was The Hope
eugenesis in the United United States
wanted to use genes to identify the type
of people holding back society and the
Soviet Union wanted to figure out how to
pull them up and there was also a major
incentive for Soviets to reject any
suggestion of genetic determinism not
being murdered a 1936 meeting at the
house of scientists in Moscow was
convened to identify the fraud of
fascist and parh fascist scientists who
engaged in the falsification of biology
with fascist meaning anyone who believed
in medical genetics scientists whose
ideas were deemed detrimental to the
state were increasingly arrested and
that year the flow of scientific
information with the global Community
had been nearly cut off all exchanges of
books and articles had to be conducted
through the allun Society of cultural
relations with foreign countries which
was essentially a wing of the people's
commissariat of internal affairs the
nkvd Stalin's secret police a clear line
had been drawn between the scientists
who believed in Western genetics and
those like lka who rejected it the
geneticists were overwhelmingly targeted
in Stalin's Great Purge in which
Millions ions were arrested and
700,000 were killed Lenka not only
Survived The Purge Soviet biology became
Lenka biology he was appointed president
of the Lenin Academy making him the top
agricultural official in the Soviet
Union a peasant with no special training
had worked his way up the ranks to
become an autocrat in charge of the
agricultural Affairs of Soviet Society
one of lenka's first orders of business
when he rose to power was to eliminate
Heretics he folded an nkvd officer into
his Department that would help faret out
the gene believers who were charged with
being the same as eugenicists racists
and fascists the geneticists who didn't
have the good sense to stay quiet or
outwardly lie were dropping like like
the fruit flies in Morgan's research lab
most were arrested and killed others
died from the stress of it all and
sometimes it was impossible to tell what
actually happened to them like with CV
Nikolai cive had pioneered the theory of
a cell's cytoskeleton and he was to
Lenka an enemy his demise typified the
way Lenka persecuted his detractors it
wasn't like a mob hit where he ordered
Ed anyone to be arrested or killed
instead his Target was called out in
some publication scientific or public
with a charge that his theories were
dangerous or subversive to the state
then he just waited and let Stalin's
secret police sorted out in the
perversion of knowledge Vadim beerstein
relayed a line from the media campaign
against CV The Institute of genetics of
the Academy of Sciences not only did not
criticize Professor CV's fascistic
nonsense but even did not dissociate
itself from his theories which support
the racial theories of fascists the
official record is that culv died of a
stroke in 1940 his wife Maria also a
scientist poisoned herself the same day
in her deathbed letter she said that
culv had a brief moment of mental
Clarity before dying during which he
said how I wish that everybody would
wake up years later biochemist Ilia
zarski admitted that culve had been
poisoned by the
nkvd notice that the Institute of
genetics of the Academy of Sciences was
named as directly responsible for not
rejecting kulsa that was done as one
small part of a massive campaign to
smear vaval like sena's former Patron
and chief competition and vice president
of the Lenin Academy under him to Stalin
and Lysa vov was a sabator and he was
considered a wrecker in Soviet law
someone who undermines the state he was
arrested as a foreign agent in
1941 and sentenced to death was it
because Lenka pointed a finger at him or
was it vavilov's willingness to
communicate with foreign
scientists probably both although his
sentence was commuted from life to 20
years vavilov died in prison just 2
years later his death certificate cites
a decline of cardiac activity while some
Scholars suggest he died of starvation
Soviet leader Leonid brn's niece lubov
breva said that vov was thrown to his
death into a pit of
lime after the close of world War II
mcgrawhill considered publishing an
English version of lysa's 1943 heredity
and its variability an adviser said that
the book was so wrong and so wholly
rejected by the broader scientific
community that it would actually do
science a great service to make his
Follies known mcra Hill decided not to
publish the book but king's crown press
did with the purpose of exposing l lka
and it worked the cracks in Lysa ISM
were spreading 120 scientists attended a
post-war celebration of the Academy of
Sciences at which he spoke about the
process of
reproductivity there Lenka said that
cells combine via a love-based marriage
and that fertilization is mutual
digestion he described the specific
process of the creation of human life as
the egg Digest the sperm and at the same
time the sperm digests the egg they
assimilate each other this assimilation
is not complete we know in our persons
what happens when it is so we belch
segregation is Nature's belching
unassimilated material is belched out
Mom Dad if you're watching this video
and I know you are I just want to thank
you for beling me into the
world Stalin turned again to lka after a
famine that enveloped the Soviet Union
from 1946 to 1947 in part because they
sold much of their Grain on the
international market to Spur weak
economic activity and didn't have enough
for themselves they discussed branched
wheat as a solution but Lena's
correspondence to Stalin later on veered
away from actual science and into nearly
unintelligible and therefore
uncriticizable
Theory I dare say that mentalism Moranis
Vice Min Neo Darwinism is a bouis
metaphysical science of living bodies of
living nature developed in Western
capitalist countries not for
agricultural purposes but for
reactionary Eugenics racism and other
purposes okay his Academy hadn't done
much of anything in years half of its
members didn't survive the war and many
of the rest had been arrested or died of
old age bnst and geneticist Nikolai sein
who had been a strong supporter of Lysa
was done with the whole charade ctin
wrote to Stalin that it was time for the
Soviet Union's scientific Community to
embrace genetics real serious genetics
once again because an atmosphere of fear
of one-sided criticism and of biased
Exposition had overtaken the academy cin
wrote to Andre janov Stalin's Main
propagandist and his likely successor
that none of Lena's varieties of wheat
had produced success in 20 years and
lenka's scientific domain had been
cultivated into an ideological
bureaucracy that can only be dismantled
by state intervention seemingly everyone
knew this aside from Stalin Lenka and
their most rabid supporters but even
when Lenka was subject to his own
methods of persecution being called a
sabator it it just didn't matter as long
as he had Stalin's personal support he
and his reputation would survive a
propaganda campaign in 1948 that was
meant to contrast Soviet science with
Western science included poems and songs
celebrating the eternal glory of the
academician Lenka and stores sold busts
of him Lena was made out to be a
scientific Miracle Worker and he fed
into Stalin's all knowing magical
delusions Simon in writes that Lenka
testified that he owed his success to
Stalin's teaching about gradual
concealed unnoticeable quantitative
changes leading to Rapid radical
qualitative changes permitting Soviet
biologists to discover in Plants the
transformation of one species into
another and that Lena's Journal
agrobiology detailed supposedly
successful efforts to alter species with
oats turning into barley sunflowers
turning into strangle weed and pine
trees becoming fur trees Nikita kushev
said later on that all Stalin knew of
Soviet life came from watching movies
showing beautiful Farms with burgeoning
Bountiful harvests and happy people
Stalin's Russia and Stalin's biology
were fiction Stalin confidently
introduced a program with a comically
long name his plan for shelter belt
plantings grass crop rotation and the
construction of ponds and reservoirs to
secure high yield and stable harvest in
step and Forest step regions of the
European part of the USSR lka became
involved in the forestry operating on
his theory of self thinning that stated
planting an oak seedling with several
planted close to it would encourage them
all to pull their defensive resources
against weeds then at exactly the right
time all but one of the seedings would
know to sacrifice themselves for the
benefit of the lucky
remainder none of this worked and most
of the forests
died within a year or two then on March
5th 1953 so did Joseph Stalin and it was
the beginning of the end of trophy mka's
Legacy the real scientists started to
flow back into Soviet genetics research
Lenka and his allies didn't have the
social or political Capital to swing
Stalin's reputation around anymore it
was a very slow process process over a
period of years academics friendly to
modern genetics and probably more
importantly embarrassed by Lena's neol
lamarian theories multiplied an article
in the Botanical Journal should have
been lenka's killshot AA rukan revealed
that one of lenka's most fantastic
claims that he had successfully turned a
hornbean tree into a completely
different hazelnut tree could be proven
to be a fraud the hazelnut was simply
grafted on the hornbeam tree was not
biologically coer into changing species
rukan even Tracked Down the guy who made
the Graft in
1923 Lenka submitted a letter insisting
that it was real and Botanical Journal
published rian's article lenka's
rebuttal and photographs of the trees
graphs somehow Lenka managed to run the
academy for three more years until a 22
Page Letter detailing his crimes against
genetics was signed by 300 academics and
submitted to the Central Committee at
last he was forced to resign but like
the fabled Cockroach of a nuclear winter
Lenka survived Nikita kev's 1956 speech
on the cult of personality and its
consequences began the Soviet Union's
process of D
stalinization but Lenka kept finding new
ways to do damage in 1957 kusf
challenged the Soviet Union to generate
more milk than the United States and lka
had a solution within months crossbreed
Prime Jersey bulls with regular cows and
then pamper them lka in insisted that
feeding and fattening the cows would
make their progyny fat healthy producers
too and by then the trait would be
permanently established the Ministry of
Agriculture set lenka's plan into motion
and ordered Bulls from his farm their
follow-up analysis to the program which
used the math and statistics Lanka
ignored showed that lenka's farm yields
were a substandard when they controlled
for all the Machinery investment and
electricity lka used over 10 years the
average cow in the Soviet Union produced
over
35% less milk lysenko was actually right
about improving yields crossbreeding
purebred Jersey bulls with normal cows
results in a generation of better milk
producers the problem is that the
following generation reverts back to
regular milk production or Worse without
any way to recover the bloodline Lena's
plan obliterated the Soviet Union's
pedigree of Jersey bulls and finally
truly it was over for him after 40 years
trophy lenka's reputation had finally
succumb to Trophy
mka to The Bitter End he claimed to be a
victim and a misunderstood martyr Lauren
Graham is a professor emeritus of
Science History at MIT he's one of the
few living people in the west to have
met Lenka and discussed his work with
him in lenka's ghost Graham tells of
running into him in moscow's House of
scientists in 1971 and Lysa told Graham
that he'd made several mistakes in
articles that he'd written he said the
most important mistake was that you
accused me of being responsible for the
deaths of many Russian biologists such
as the well-known geneticist n vov I
disagreed with vov on biological issues
but I had nothing to do with his death
in prison you know I have never even
been a member of the Communist party and
I am not responsible for what either the
party or the secret police did in
biology trophy mka died in
1976 having never considered himself
responsible for anything not the shotty
pseudo science not the persecution of
his peers not the millions dead from
starvation in the Soviet Union or the
tens of millions dead in the great
Chinese famine that was substantially a
product of following lenka's
agricultural plans since then the world
has treated Lenka and his ideas as a
perverse joke the ultimate measure of a
scientific
irresponsibility but even in death just
like he did so many times times in life
trophy mka has once again weasel his way
back into relevance in the last 25 years
trophy mka's Legacy has been given a new
life particularly in the Russian
Federation because Lena may have been so
outrageously wrong that he started to be
a little
bit right geneticist through the 20th
century had never thought that one's
experiences and environment played no
role in the expression of genes but the
emerging field of epigenetics suggests
that the factors in one's life those all
encompassing nutrients like Sena spoke
of can actually alter one's genetic
sequence or at least the expression of
it in a way that affects future
Generations early on we understood that
DNA shapes RNA which which then makes
proteins that build out an organism and
that information only flows from the DNA
when DNA changes it's a mutation not a
response to an input or stimulus Watson
and cric mapped out the double helix of
DNA in 1953 and by the mid 1960s we
understood the basic mechanisms of gene
expression with genes turning on and off
but transgenerational epigenetic
inheritance Works suggests that jeans
are more of a massive collection of
information that can be accessed rather
than a rock solid recipe Graham
describes it like a giant library with a
human's 20,000 genes like books that are
read often or not at all and just like
in a library sometimes you need to get
special permission to access a book and
new volumes are coming in while others
are discarded Graham extends the
metaphor to say that books that can be
read are like like expressed genes that
are turned on while ones that are
inaccessible are not expressed or turned
off increasing evidence suggests that
chemical groups can attach themselves to
DNA in a way that influences expression
methylation when it happens
demethylation when it's reversed which
then may be transferred via inheritance
we've known for some time that plants
work this way the question is whether
people do Michael mean's work with rats
at McGill University has shown that pups
that were licked frequently by their
mothers good lickers grew up to be good
Liquors themselves and so did their
offspring it was the same for bad
Liquors and when populations were cross
fostered meaning pups of bad Liquors
were given to good Liquors the pups and
their offspring became good Liquors too
and yeah being adopted by a rat mom who
sucked at licking turned you and your
kids into bad lickers it seems obvious
that this is a case of learned behavior
just being passed down through
generations but the researchers found
different methylation patterns in the
licked rat's DNA rat moms who were good
lickers removed methyl groups from a
pup's DNA their outside stimulus altered
DNA's ability to express it's a start
but rat licking is one thing and
starving people is
another over 20,000 Dutch civilians
starve to death in the winter Famine of
1944 to
1945 with caloric intake dropping by as
much as
80% the Dutch famine cohort study has
tracked every measurable detail about
those who lived through through the
famine and their descendants you'd
expect that the terrible health
conditions they suffered through might
affect their own offspring but the
researchers found what they call the
grandmother effect the grandchildren of
mothers who are pregnant while subject
to the famine showed markedly High rates
of a range of diseases and disorders
from diabetes to breast cancer and
depression even though their own mothers
were in good health through their
pregnancies something appears to have
happened to pregnant mothers during the
Dutch famine that not only showed up
down the line but actually skipped a
generation but the really interesting
research comes from an area in the North
of Sweden called UIC two centuries ago
their climate was volatile enough that
the people who lived in overol swung
between feast and famine some years they
starved other years they ate like kings
here too the grandchildren showed
serious health problems even when their
own parents had grown up in cities with
consistent health and diet grandsons of
men who feasted in the Years just before
puberty died early while granddaughters
of women who starved during pregnancy
died early transgenerational EP genetic
evidence suggests that our genes are a
lot more malleable than we thought some
media Outlets especially in Russia have
declared that this means trophime Lenka
was actually right all along that
acquired characteristics are heritable
but Lauren Graham puts it succinctly
where lenu was right he was not original
and where he was original he was not
right his work related to the hor rity
of acquired characteristics has nothing
to do with modern epigenetic research
and his work with vernalization was no
Discovery at all trophime lenko was not
a serious scientist and he was not a
serious person but his shadow still
looms over science who wants to conduct
research that might link them with the
pseudo science of Lysa ISM it's imp
possible impossible to know how many
years behind Humanity's understanding of
genetics is because of stalins Lenas and
the Soviet Union's total refusal to work
alongside the rest of the world and
we'll never know how much research won't
ever be conducted because of the
possible connotations with bad science
the really strange thing about all this
is that Stalin Soviet Union did not
reject modernity in other disciplines
chemistry was chemistry and although
there were differing opinions about
whether science should serve the state
or be conducted for its own advancement
it was recognizable to the Western World
physics even more so the USSR was able
to test a nuclear device in 1949
precisely because they didn't believe
Adams split on their own to fuel the
class struggle and Stalin's death came
only 4 years before Sputnik one's
successful launch and thre Monon orbit
of Earth but genetics and biology were a
mess Nicholas studentsov trained a mouse
to run to food after hearing a buzzer
and found that future Generations were
naturally better at the maze children
took 100 14 repetitions theirs took 29
and the Next Generation only 11 except
it turned out that student soft was just
getting better at training the mice and
when Olga leesin had video evidence of
having created living tissue out of dead
tissue basically
necromancy she'd actually just filmed
cells decomposing and then played the
film in reverse
there's an old joke from the Soviet era
that the future is always certain it was
the past that kept changing and such is
the case with trophy Lenka whose Legacy
waffles between Visionary hero and
crackery so ridiculous that to be
accused of behaving like him is a
scientific Scarlet Letter his reputation
like that of his Soviet Union exhibits
that peculiar characteristic he thought
living organisms had it seems to change
species depending on its environment and
one of our few transgenerational
scientific truths is that troph L sena's
name will never be forgotten because
some ideas are so bad they never truly
die and as always thanks for
watching
[Applause]
for